So the irony in these systems is that...
the irony in predictive systems
is that they're actually unpredictable at least
at first when machine learning systems
are new they're often inaccurate
which is actually not what we expect from our
things. You know, 60% or 70%
accuracy is actually really good for a
first pass at a machine learning system
but even ninety percent accuracy isn't
enough to make a predictive
system feel right. Because it's making
decisions all the time. And it's going to be
making mistakes all the time. It's fine
if your house is a couple of degrees
cooler than you'd like or warmer
whatever. But if your wheelchair refuses
to go to a drinking fountain that's next to
a door because it's been trained
on doors, and it can't tell that what you're
saying is "I want to go to that thing
next to the door," not "to the door,"
that's a real problem. And for
all the times the system gets things
right, you judge it on its mistakes.
And mistakes create anxiety. And anxiety
is an incredibly heavy kind of cognitive
load to bear. And a little doubt
about whether a supposedly smart system
is going to do the right thing is enough to
turn a user experience that's right most
of the time, into one that's more
trouble than it's worth. The last
issue comes as a result of these previous two:
Control. How do we maintain some level
of control over these devices when
their behavior is by definition statistical
and unpredictable? On the one hand, you know,
you can mangle your device's predictive
behavior by giving it too much data.
I visited Nest one time
in their early days. And they told me that
none of the Nests in their office
actually worked. Because they were constantly
fiddling with them.
They're constantly, like, playing around with...
And in machine learning this is
what's called "over-training". On the other hand,
if I have no direct way to control it other
than through my own behavior, how do i
adjust it? So Amazon and Netflix's
recommendation systems which are
machine learning systems for predicting what
you might like... they've been around for
a long time. They give you some context
about why they recommended
something, why they're doing something.
But what if my only interface
is a garden hose? What do I do? How do I
get it to stop spraying water? As interesting
as these issues are, I actually think
that most importantly what they represent
is that we're entering into a
new relationship with our device ecosystem.
We're experiencing a sea change in
our relationship to the built world. So think
of a sewing machine. It's really complex.
But it basically acts in response to us.
Computers acting autonomously erode this
simple tool to user relationship. At the
dawn of computing in the late 1940s,
cyberneticists like Norbert Wiener
philosophized about this
increasingly complex relationship
between people and computers. And how it
was fundamentally different than
the way that we've interacted with other kinds
of machines other kinds of tools.
So developers who are working in
supervisory control of
manufacturing machine--so basically,
you know, things that build cars, things that...
are giant robots in factories...
they've actually been having
to deal with these questions
very pragmatically for a very long time.
Now thanks to the Internet of Things, it's
everybody's problem. So this is a
diagram by the great Tom Sheridan who was
a brilliant engineer and
Bill Verplank. This is from 1978. In which
what they're trying to do is
they're trying to illustrate four ways
that semi-autonomous computers and
humans can work together to solve a
problem. This actually comes out of
an amazing project when they were--
in the freaking 70s!--they were doing these like
semi-autonomous submersible robots that
would like go deep underwater and...
they were so deep underwater that... you'd
have to control them from the surface. But
you didn't have like really great control.
You have to tell them what to do... and...
this is like 01975 they were doing this.
Sheridan continued to think about this.
He was a smart guy. By 02000 he'd actually
expanded that idea to create this
framework. And he defined a spectrum of
responsibility between people and
computers. So it ranges from the top,
#1... so i'll read it for the folks
in back
#1 "The computer offers no assistance,
humans must make all decisions and actions."
So it ranges from #1, where humans do
all the work--that's like, you know,
you writing an essay (unless you're in school
in which case you Google for it) or
you knitting. To #10, computers doing all the work:
"The computer decides everything and
acts autonomously, ignoring the human."
That's your car's fuel injection controller.
So, of course, the goal is to get
to something down here near 9 or 10.
That's kind of the maximum reduction
on cognitive load. But for a system to
qualify for that it needs to be
very stable. Its effects need to
be very predictable. And more importantly
its role needs to be very well embedded
and understood in society. We trust it
to do that thing. At the airport we trust
the monorail computer to work
without human intervention. But
we don't trust the plane auto pilot to do that.
Even though, as I understand that,
planes can basically fly themselves these days.
it's not socially embedded yet.
Predictive IOT devices generally fall
between 5 to 7 today.
And probably for the near future. The problem
is that this is the exact range
where you're maximizing someone's cognitive
load. Because you're making them make
a lot of decisions, but not necessarily
doing all the work for them. So
the result of the automation had really
better be worth it, in order for
that system to work. Moreover
that relationship fundamentally undermines
what we expect from our tools. Because
when that tool is trying to anticipate
what we're trying to do and trying to get
in front of us in doing it,
it fundamentally changes our working
relationship with it.
you